on saturday night facebook acknowledged
that an anti-vaxx post was the most
popular post on the platform in q1 of
2021 that's right
facebook is spreading anti-vaxxed news
on their platform at scale and it's
worth digging into this because it is a
very complicated issue because facebook
isn't the person actually sharing this
it's us
consumers are choosing to share and
amplify anti-vaxx posts and of course
facebook is the platform allowing that
so the grand debate
will continue
should facebook be editing the posts of
their members or should they be a common
carrier should they be
like the phone
and they just allow people to talk on
the phone obviously i think we all know
that it's much different than just using
the phone because here something can
trend and a lot of people can see it on
each other so last wednesday and this
story is a little complicated but i
think it's worth us going over
last wednesday facebook released their
first ever content transparency report
which covered the second quarter of
2021. it's important to get the quarter
straight here second quarter obviously
april may june 1st quarter january
february march four quarters in the year
three months in each you might remember
that we covered facebook's internal
transparency battle on episode 1247 of
this week in stardust back in july this
was the story in which the new york
times kevin rose inserted himself into
the story by creating the facebook top
10 twitter handle using data from crowd
tango which is a comp that facebook
bought and it's a social media
monitoring tool that just tells you
what's popular on the platform
and the sort of negative take on that on
twitter which is slap leaning was that
facebook is right-leaning big shocker
facebook is something that people all
across the united states use and it's
right leading twitter is something that
elites in coastal cities in democratic
places and journalists are addicted to
and it leans left there's no shocker
here i think we all understand that
these two platforms have a position just
like fox news
uh and msnbc might have uh a leaning
correct i think we all agree on that now
facebook's transparency report is
including widely viewed posts as a
section
and uh this featured the top 20 most
viewed posts over the three-month period
from april to june of 2021 the list
included a bulldog puppy meme which is
in my wheelhouse and i'm all for a post
from joe biden and was mostly filled
with response baiting posts like what is
something you will never eat no matter
how hungry you get let me think about
that
i think that you really can't
objectively answer this until you're
starving on a raft in the middle of the
ocean so that's a great viral query that
people will respond to and
we all understand how the signal works
on
facebook anything that increases the
time you spend on facebook or on youtube
will get shown more
and that is the nature of these
algorithms
the nature of the algorithms being built
is take all the signal you can find a
like a click
maybe you're scrolling on your phone
maybe forwarding to a friend
writing a comment any of those uh
variables
those behaviors those actions those
engagements those are all words we use
in the industry those engagements are
signal that they should show that post
to more people if you show it to more
people or different groups of people and
it keeps growing then you keep showing
it to similarly minded people which
creates the classic echo chamber but
that is the nature of algorithms and in
fact the people who write these
algorithms
are not picking a side
they're not picking a side they're
picking winning as a business how do you
win as a business you get more eyeballs
for a longer period of time this means
if something is shocking or outrageous
and more people comment on it then you
show it more misinformation arguably is
going to draw a bigger response than
just plain old information if you said
hey the journal of new england medicine
or whatever or this doctor said the
following things about the covid vaccine
that might not draw a response but if
you said bill gates is putting a
microchip in your body yada
this might actually draw a bigger
response which then the algorithm which
is very clever at extending your time on
site but very stupid when it comes to
helping society again the algorithm is
not optimized for making society better
it's optimized for making facebook more
money and that is the key problem and by
the way it's only a key problem if the
person running the company
doesn't care about society or cares
about making money more than society and
let's face it that is the nature of mark
zuckerberg he has always cared more
about growing facebook and his own
pocketbook than he has about society
period and of story feel free to mention
me i'm taking a twitter break anyway
oddly the top 20 posts only included one
in which covid was mentioned so this was
weird journalists have got their hooks
into it they're looking at this
transparency report and they're
wondering what's going on it could be
that maybe facebook is starting to pay
attention and maybe deselect stuff from
being shared the mind wanders when you
don't have information and when you get
some information it creates more
questions sometimes than answers so this
is a very interesting moment but this
was the q2 report which then led
everybody to say hey wait where is the
q1 report now once you leave something
out
when you make a sin of omission
journalists are really good at this i
know i've been talking the last couple
of episodes about where journalists
don't have a lot of information and
maybe they don't do a good job and
they're doing click baiting and they've
got their own interest to get
subscribers or to get advertisers this
is where actually journalists can do a
great job when something's missing
they'll be they'll notice it they're
like detectives when they're at their
best and something's missing they're
going to ask that question so on friday
the new york times reported that
facebook had a transparency report
prepared for q1
but decided to not release it
for fear of looking bad
so why here's the quote from the new
york times the most viewed link was a
news article with a headline suggesting
that the coronavirus vaccine was at
fault for the death of a florida doctor
the article in question was published by
the chicago tribune with the headline a
healthy doctor died two weeks after
getting a coven 19 vaccine cdc is
investigating why and this is the kind
of headline that we've all been seeing
where
the fear-mongering amongst the press and
the way the press presents information
is completely at worst they're doing it
to get
it the most cynical version of why
publishers are writing these headlines
is fear-mongering to keep you tuned into
cnn reggae news everybody's dying of
covet and then they never tell you
exactly what's happening you'll hear
that pediatric
icus are being are full but they never
tell you how many people are in a
pediatric icu they never tell you the
denominator they never tell you the
numbers they tell you it's surging they
tell you it's breaking all the stuff
they don't really want to give you the
numbers because the numbers actually
might be there were four pediatric beds
and now there's five and that fifth
child was put in their regular icu and
it's not a problem when the news is
playing these kind of games they lose
trust and so here you have it facebook
has this headline with the chicago
tribune which i think is a kind of crazy
anecdotal story one doctor and the cdc
is investigating why you really don't
want to print a headline like that one
could argue that the chicago tribune is
doing a bad job by putting a headline
like that and people have which is it's
fear-mongering it's done to get clicks
if a healthy doctor died two weeks after
getting the kova 19 vaccine they should
put how was he hit by a bus
was she somebody who had an allergic
reaction to it what are the details here
and the cdc investigating that doesn't
really mean anything maybe they're
investigating all people who died after
a vaccine shop
i want to welcome harry hurst you know
him as the co-ceo and co-founder of the
company pipe you've been on twitter over
the past year you've probably heard me
and my besties a number of which got
their beaks wet talking about all the
excitement around pipe and their
fundraising and the product they're
bringing to market i thought i'd have
harry come on and explain it to y'all
harry welcome to the program thank you
jason what kind of vetting do you do on
the companies and what size company is
it best for so the beauty of being a
trading platform is that we can service
companies of all shapes and sizes so
we've got companies that are just
getting started out have a hundred
thousand in arr all the way up to uh
publicly traded companies on the
platform with hundreds of millions in
arr and every company in between so
there's a different offering in terms of
trading limit size and bid price for
each company stage in terms of vetting
the way that we work with the companies
that when you sign up for pipe you
connect your bank account your
accounting system and your payment
processor and within 24 hours the next
business morning we're gonna give you
your trading limit the amount that
you're able to trade at any one time and
the bid price the amount of cents on the
dollar that the capital markets are
willing to pay for the annualized value
of your revenue streams all right thanks
again harry for coming on the pod and
explaining that with pipe.com there is
no debt no loans and most importantly to
me as an angel investor no dilution if
you sign up at pipe.com twist they'll
eliminate all your trading fees for one
full year what a generous offer pipe.com
twist so you can save up to tens of
thousands of dollars happy piping
everybody
you